welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and now locked into
the channel where we've been watching
The Watchmen to break down everything
that you need to know about the new
season on HBO throughout this video
we'll be recapping the fifth entry in
the series thus far and discussing where
the show could be heading in the future
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to watch
episode 5 yet and don't want to know
what happens then I highly suggest that
you turn off now without the way I just
want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of Watchmen episode 5 okay
so just a quick recap to bring you up to
speed on everything so far in watchmen
sister Knight has uncovered what looks
to be a huge conspiracy inside the
police that seemingly shows one of its
high-ranking officers was linked with
the group known as the seventh cavalry
that carried out attacks on the police
and public after this officer captain
Gerda was murdered it drew the attention
of the FBI who sent in their agent
Laurie Blake in order to investigate the
crime we become aware of a trillionaire
named lady true who is operating in the
area and may have connections to the
mystery as well as several side
characters such as Looking Glass who
gets a lot of attention throughout this
episode this kind of Mirrors excuse the
pun the original Watchmen aesthetic with
the source material tending to focus on
a single character such as the Rorschach
issue the dr. Manhattan one and so on
episode 5 itself opens in hoboken in
1985 where we join a group of Christian
missionaries that are trying to convert
people to their religion we later learn
that one of the attendees at the funfair
is a young Looking Glass and throughout
the protagonists stroll through the area
we see a magazine for the bike method
which was a workout program formulated
by Ozymandias and a group of topknots
these are the group of street thugs that
ended up killing the first Nite Owl in
his home but they also terrorized a lot
of people in the graphic novel Looking
Glass or wade as he's called plucks up
the courage to go and talk to them
spouting off about the Doomsday Clock
and he's mocked by them before being
taken away by a girl to a house of
mirrors there's a lip service paid to
the Doomsday Clock being one minute to
midnight and for those who don't know in
the original work this
pretty much seen as the countdown to
Armageddon Ozymandias launched his hoax
alien invasion at this point and United
the world into fighting one common enemy
we actually see this play out in the
episode this entry is predominantly
about doubles reflections and duplicates
and we see this exemplified early on
with LG walking through a house of
mirrors
there are several twins throughout the
episode and we also get the Jew ality of
human character and this is cemented
here with the topknot girl being clad in
black trying to seduce the whiter than
white Christian missionary after she
leaves him strip naked in the Hall of
Mirrors the attack commences and it all
comes crashing down
now the ringing in his ear that LG gets
is because when the alien landed it
launched a psychic blast that massively
messed with people mentally killing many
and psychologically damaging a lot of
those that survived this kind of carries
on through looking-glasses psyche in the
episode and we can see that he has a lot
of problems it's clear that the
character never really left that Hall of
Mirrors and like Batman with Crime Alley
or any of the superhero that was birth
out of trauma and early age they are
just a young kid scared out of their
wit's trying to deal with the world
around them looking glass exits to see
that there are bodies strewn everywhere
similar to the graphic novel and we
finally get a look at the alien squid
that every fan will remember it's the
best introduction at the season so far
and whilst Watchmen has its haters right
now I can't see anyone denying that this
entire segment recaptures the feeling of
the original work we learn that Looking
Glass also known as wade often spends
his time on the other side of a mirror
whether he's looking at a focus group
test were staring at people in an
interrogation room
the character is often peering into
people's souls past the visions that
they want to show the world and looking
behind the mask ignoring the mirror of
the world that they present
looking-glasses mask is also literal as
it turns out it is a form of protection
from psychic blasts and this becomes the
sort of tinfoil hat of the series that
also hints at the true intentions of the
character Wade took to becoming a
policeman because like many he is still
completely terrified of the alien attack
from 30 years ago and he wishes to
create a false outward persona that he
is still in control it's an awesome
psychological study and I have to say
that early on in this episode
it really got its hooks into me watching
him still pine for a woman that he
ruined a relationship with due to his
paranoia it's heartbreaking and seeing
him leading a help group really makes
the character relatable looking-glasses
this shows Rorschach and it's
fascinating to watch him deal with the
duality of living in fear while it's
also presenting this devil-may-care
gritty exterior the character even eats
raw beans which was a big food source
for Rorschach in the original graphic
novel she in fact it's pretty much all
you ate and it's clear that he is aping
the character in many ways we also get
implications that hooded justice and
captain metropolis were in a gay
relationship with one another on the TV
show with in a TV show that is slowly
becoming the seasons black freighter
either way Wade is paranoid to the core
ready to run to his bunker at the first
sign of a little squid fall and he lives
in constant fear we get mention of this
one Wade is analyzing the group early on
in the episode and similar to them he is
scared but he just doesn't want to admit
it he even puts up a wall when asked if
he's scared saying at the therapy
meeting that he isn't afraid and this
again mirrors at the duality within him
at forever pets we witness a cloning
procedure that to placate animals and I
believe that this is one of the
procedures that lady Tru has adapted for
humans Wade also comes face to face with
his long-lost love and as someone whose
dog was put down two weeks ago this
scene really got amazing Cynthia
incinerated dog for looking a little
small yeah these aren't good people
through Cynthia we discover that angela
has been using nostalgia pills and this
is a slight deviation from the graphic
novel with that initially being a
perfume fragrance that was supposed to
bring back memories this was created by
Veidt as one of his top selling ranges
however here the pills can cause
hallucinations and they forced the brain
to recall the past they have been
outlawed due to side effects which
include psychosis which it looks like
it's going to become a big focus of the
next episode later we see Angela swallow
a handful of these before she's arrested
and it's clear she's been
self-medicating with these to get to the
bottom of Jude's death anyway looking
glass is clearly helping many but this
mask is quickly pulled away by a new
member who questions if he's truly as
unafraid as he says he is throughout his
life Wade has been tormented by women
and I can see this being a big point of
content
for the character going forward whether
it's the girl in the house of mirrors
Cynthia helping him even if there's an
undertone that she thinks that he's a
loser
Lori mocking his mask or the woman at
the meeting it seems like most of the
females that he encounters are there to
belittle him and lead him along the only
one who isn't is Angela
but we do see lookingglass betray her
later in the episode and I believe that
the focus towards the end of the season
will be him trying to repair this
relationship the woman at the meeting
turns out to be a member of the seven
cavalry and after discovering that her
ride home was the truck involved in the
police shooting in the opening episode
he follows her to an empty warehouse
where we discovered the Cavalry's real
plan they wished to open a portal to
orchestrate another attack now there is
some big bombshells that come in the
episode including the fact that Wade has
been selected to become a member and was
purposely lured here which again cements
the female manipulation on the character
also those who thought that there was a
shady side to Senator Joe keen or proven
right here when he's shown to have taken
of the leadership duties from Jed
Crawford keen orchestrated the bomb at
Judds funeral as a false flag attack to
paint himself out as a victim in order
to drive his electoral push and to also
stop Jude's autopsy from going ahead
keen says that his goal is to keep the
peace but in order to carry this out he
needs LG to arrest Angela to you to her
involvement in the investigation
surrounding Judd he doesn't know if she
killed Jude or is just getting in the
way of finding out who did it
all he knows is that she is going to be
a problem as a thank you or squid pro
quo Keane reveals that he will play him
a tape that shows the truth a video
message from Ozymandias addressed a
future President Robert Redford that
confirms that the squid attack was a
hoax
Veidt has manipulated the press and
media to get Redford into office and he
selected the actor to continue his goal
to build a utopia for mankind if I wish
to weaponize fear to unite the world and
this is completely mind-blowing for Wade
who has lived his entire life scared to
death of the next attack Vitus being
manipulating the squid fall to provide
an almost drip feed of fear to the
public and he wishes to form a
partnership with the new president to
make the world better I love how there
are TVs on the wall similar to Ozzie set
up in Karnak that all relate is
mind-blowing mess
[ __ ] - wait we then cut to Ozymandias
who is being loaded into the catapult
and launched into the outskirts of his
prison we finally see the character LAN
on what looks to be a moon circulating a
larger planet most likely Jupiter by
discovers the bodies of all that he is
launched into the cold reaches of space
and using their corpses he writes a
message on the moon's surface saying
save me this triumph is cut short though
by the game warden who Yanks the
character back into his prison and is
revealed to be a clone of mr. Philips
now personally I believe that after
Redford was elected as he realized that
the world was not going to become a
utopia as he planned and after becoming
deflated by this he sold his company to
true industries in exchange for solitude
from the planet we know that true can
change environments - - her pod in
Episode four and I believe that she has
scored Ozzy to this moon where he used
mental about the rest of his life in
peace true doesn't want him to return so
as part of their negotiations she
created the game warden to keep him in
the grounds whilst initially Ozzy
thought this to be a paradise he quickly
realized it was a prison and nurse
wanted to escape now it may be dr.
Manhattan behind it as he is capable of
space travel and there is also mention
of their God abandoning them so this
could be the case but I guess we'll find
out if you've been keeping up with my
series and you'll know that I jump back
and forth between the two theories each
week so yeah I thought I'd just lay out
both possibilities here bites pit ends
with him being arrested by the game
warden and we cut back to earth for
another focused test we get a
reimagining of Careless Whisper
which has been present throughout the
episode and watch his looking-glass goes
in and tricks Angela into confessing
that her grandfather killed Jude and
that she covered up the murder the
cactus on Wade's desk which has been
bugged picks this up and Laurie hears it
all leaving her office gun pointed at
Angela Wade sits at his desk pulling his
mask down to hide behind it and what
he's done though it looks like the
character is in the clear the episode
ends with Wade's house being broken into
by cavalry members which once more
cements that he has been misled and
manipulated similar to the Christian
leader at the start the girl in the
funhouse and many more throughout his
life Wade has been told to deliver a
message that has ultimately led him down
a dock
path now in Episode six it is revealed
that angela has been taking her
grandfather wills nostalgia and that she
has been using this to discover the
truth about the character will did
predict in Episode four that she would
honor the truth about him and this looks
to be the case in the upcoming entry
angela is clearly becoming lost in the
fantasy unable to distinguish between
her life and wills and it looks like he
similar to her took up the role of a
police officer
this may cross paths with judge joining
of the force which could show how well
knew that he was a cavalry member as for
Looking Glass I personally believe that
he will defeat the cavalry group and
will be the one to unearth the secret
about Senator Kean which will mean that
the town will descend into war with the
masked policemen going up against the
masked members of the group no one will
be able to trust anyone and thus
everyone will be left fearful and
paranoid except for LG who as we have
seen has overcome it all it will be
interesting to see where it goes but I
am hooked on the show at the moment and
can't wait to see what way it develops
over the coming weeks
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on this episode and if you agree with
the theories in this video comment below
and let me know and if you enjoy this
then please give it a thumbs up and
don't forget to check out our breakdown
of the series so far which goes over all
of the things you missed and where we
think the show could be heading we also
do a podcast called watching The
Watchmen in which we break down every
issue of the Watchmen page by page and
also give our thoughts on Doomsday Clock
I'll leave that linked at the end and if
you want to come chat to me after the
video then make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey white over
to my discord server which will be
linked in the description below those
are the best ways to keep up to date
with all the latest videos and the
channel so hopefully I see you over
there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the marble phase 3 part 2 boxer on
blu-ray which contains Black Panther
infinity war and Game Captain Marvel
more and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is like the
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
Watchmen in the comment section below
the winners gonna be chosen on the 15th
of November and the set will be shipped
up from then jabba gets the prize so
best of luck to everyone who takes part
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this
I've been definition evening the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you